hey youtubers is Charlie so big WTF news
is the Game of Thrones Season seven and
eight might get super shortened Indiana
and Dave were originally not even
thinking about doing season eight so we
got to think this through the big WTF is
just the idea that they're going to
shorten the last two seasons instead of
doing like a full 10 episode season 7
then another 10 episodes of season 8
meaning we would potentially be missing
out on 7 episodes of Game of Thrones now
this is just preliminary nothing's been
set in stone Dan and Dave were just
answering questions in a regular
interview they're like well you know
we've been thinking about shortening the
run a little bit originally it sounds
like they were envisioning 7 seasons
when they first started making the
series HBO was like we want 10 years
storage our Martin was like hey thumbs
up to that I'm totally happy to have
Game of Thrones on HBO for 10 years then
this past year at the most recent tcas
the head of HBO was like 8 seasons so it
sounds like between all three powers
here you know George R Martin HBO the
network and Dan and Dave with their
studio all had three different ideas
about how this is gonna play out
worst case scenario they go with the
shorter seasons you think well we got
all these spin-offs we can do so they'll
still be Game of Thrones even if it's
not the main series
well HBO has actually clarified the
spin-off talk they said that there
hasn't been any meaningful discussion
because they need George are Martin to
be on board with it and they would want
Dan and Dave to participate in some way
in thus far dan and Dave are really only
focusing on getting this season out in
writing the next season so officially
there's no spin-off right now although
HBO is definitely going to be pushing
for that but the way they made it sound
is like well we have a number of
characters that we could develop even
more so I actually got a little afraid
and was like are they just gonna try and
keep going forward with certain
characters I feel like if they're gonna
do a spin-off they would have better
luck going back in time and not doing
the exact same characters that they did
in the main series but that's a whole
other conversation because if we really
do get shorter season seven and eight
what does that mean for the timeline you
really have to move everything up
originally what I'd hoped is that
towards the end of season 7 Daenerys
would make landfall in Westeros with her
army the White Walkers would bring the
wall down and then for season 8 you
would just have like a season-long war
for the dawn as the White Walkers slowly
destroyed Westeros in the combined
armies of the Seven Kingdoms and
Daenerys in the east try to stop them so
still feel like looking at what's
happening in the trailer this season
Daenerys is gonna spend most of the
season trying to win over the Dothraki
so that she can make this giant army
then eventually she'll make her way to
Westeros but it seems like it's gonna
take most of the season to accomplish
well let me know what you guys think
about this we still get season seven and
eight but they're just way way shorter
they do the AMC Mad Men Breaking Bad
thing where they break up the last
season into two separate seasons it's
almost like we the Phantom or Oberyn
Martell Dan and Dave are the mountain
and they are squishing our heads to our
eyeballs pop out of their sockets oh the
horror
but the concession is is that even if we
don't get as much Game of Thrones and
they wait a couple years after it
finishes to start a spinoff we still
have the books there will always be some
form of Game of Thrones content George
our Martin will continue to write Game
of Thrones so later this year we'll get
winds of winter then you know and
hopefully in like the next four years
will get dream of spring and then who
knows after that there's a couple more
Game of Thrones books that he's been
talking about like fire and blood the
history of the Targaryen family there's
more duncan egg stuff that he's been
talking about doing and then there's all
the expanded stuff like the board games
so even if it a couple years there's no
Game of Thrones TV show I'll still be
doing Game of Thrones types of videos
but they'll be more book related more
expanded universe you get the idea
he's just kind of a bummer when you were
expecting all this awesome stuff to be
coming and then someone comes along and
says no you're only gonna get about half
of this if it's not clear though Dan and
Dave haven't really confirmed what
they're not doing there just said what
they're thinking about doing right now
like we're thinking maybe shorter run so
they didn't say it's set in stone and
they didn't say there would be no
spin-off they just said that they're
exhausted right now and they only want
to think about what's happening in the
next couple of months they're not ready
to start thinking about what's happening
in a couple years so total episode count
and spinoff
to be determined because this really
came as a shock and I just decided to do
this video early I'll still do another
bonus video on Sunday maybe it'll be a
QA if there's any specific Game of
Thrones video you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments and
there is a new round of the giveaway
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I'll just announce the
winner whenever I post that next video
on Sunday while you guys wait for that
next video to post you can click here
for the last big trailer and you can
click here for the big Tower of joy
video that I did thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high
I'll see you guys tonight
you